céline dion est une chanteuse québécoise
mais à la carrière internationale elle
vient d'enregistrer un album en anglais
elle vient également d'être consacrée
aux victoires de la musique à paris
meilleur artiste francophone et
interprète de la meilleure chanson
écrite par jean jacques goldman
elle est avec nous ce soir mais avant
écoutons là nicolas 20 qu'elle c'est là
le coeur aussi spacieux qu'une limousine
comme quoi on peut vendre des millions
d'albums sans pour autant vendre son âme
février 95 avec jean-jacques en route
vers les studios
cette chanson vous l'avez tous eu sur
les lèvres dans sa version française et
pour cause 4 millions d'albums vendus
dans l'hexagone ça c'est la version
anglaise tiré de son nouvel album
falling into you c'est vraiment une
interprète hors du commun quoi elle fait
partie des cinq grands et je mets déjà
dedans arrête affronte line et barbra
streisand par exemple elle est dans le
lot c'est nous qui en avons la chance
puisque nous sommes les premiers à
découvrir fall into you nouveau single
nouvel album est sans doute vivre bonnes
habitudes nouveau succès
si si
il est
et mme ça